from calorie count to portion sizes we
wanted to find out all the differences
between breakfast cereals in the uk and
the us this is food wars
hey everyone joe from food wars i'm
actually not in this episode because
myself connor and yuli are busy making a
new season of food wars with the new
country ooh but don't worry i'll chime
in every once in a while and be super
annoying we're doing a cereal episode
now obviously there are a lot of
breakfast cereals in the uk and the us
and we can't cover them all in one
episode so we're going to start with the
two best sellers in america which are
frosted flakes and honey nut cheerios
then after that we might get into some
fun cereals which you can't find in one
country or the other that sound good to
you irene yeah sounds great harry
first things first frosted flakes what
is going on there in the uk we actually
just call them frosties okay this is the
one time i think the uk has a better
term for something because frosties is
actually kind of cute it's like besties
in the uk frosties come in five sizes
starting with this one which is a 25
gram box which comes as part of one of
these multi packs from there we move up
to a 375 gram box
next up we've got a 500 gram box of
frosties
from there we move up to a 750 gram box
then our largest size is this one the
big one kilogram box
in the us frosted flakes also come in
four sizes we start with the 60 gram cup
which you can just add milk directly
into and eat next up we have the 24
ounce or 680 gram family size box
from there we move up to a 34 ounce
mega size but
this actually isn't the largest one we
actually go one step further with a
39.5 ounce or 11 20 gram bag
that means our largest size is 12
percent larger than the uk's in the uk
the recommended serving size for
frosties is 30 grams which means that
our largest box contains roughly 33
servings let's find out what 30 grams of
frosties actually looks like digital
scales we finally got digital scales i
leave for one episode we get the digi
scales what the heck guys i want one
how precise can we go
not very
that is
30.08 grams of frosties right now
in an actual cereal bowl that is nothing
in the u.s the recommended serving size
for frosted flakes is actually 37 grams
which is 23 more than in the uk so while
our largest packet size might be a
little bigger we're technically getting
fewer servings just 30 compared to the
uk's 33.
let's count as asmr
okay 37. it did it
i feel like you know on tinder when guys
hold like a fish in their photo i feel
like that right now
now i'm going to be honest here that is
not a realistic serving size for a
strapping young lad such as myself uh
what i'm going to do is pour out what i
would consider to be a normal bowl and
then we'll weigh that to see what it
comes to so my actual realistic serving
ended up being almost exactly double the
30 grams coming in at around 60 grams
57.5
okay this is 60.
if i was using a bowl i think this is
exactly what i would pour for myself
because i feel like what people do you
fill the entire bowl of cereal and then
you fill it up with milk but the thing i
for some reason do is i eat my cereal
out of a cup like a mug i i like that
it's deeper so i'll put that in and so i
don't know what the equivalent of that
would be but yeah cereal out of a mug
it's like it's fun the first thing to
point out here is that i really gasolit
myself and was convinced that we had
honey nut cheerios in the uk however
when i then looked into it i found that
instead they're just honey cheerios and
uh i'd imagine the whole thing although
our cameraman charlie today was
convinced of the same thing so maybe
there's just some butterfly effect has
gone on
honey churros in the uk come in six
portion sizes starting with this one
it's a 30 gram box and again it only
comes as part of a multi-pack
from there we go up to a 280 gram box
while i was looking for the portions i
found both a 370 gram box as well as
this 375 gram box it looks like this one
maybe they are trying to use less
packaging but have taken that
opportunity to give you a few less
cheerios as well who knows our next size
is this one which is a 515 gram box
and then finally our largest cheerios
box is this one
which is 575 grams hanina cheerios in
the us come in five sizes we have the
1.8 ounce or 51 gram mini cup
the classic 10.8 ounce box
the 18.8 ounce family size
the 29.4 ounce mega size
and lastly a 32 ounce or 907 gram bag
that makes the largest u.s option 57
larger than the uk's
the recommended serving size for
cheerios in the uk is again 30 grams
that means that our largest box contains
around 19 servings in the us the
recommended serving size is one cup see
that's why you should eat it out of a
cup get it which should weigh around 37
grams that's a 23 increase on the uk and
the most servings you can get in a u.s
container would be around 24.5 which is
almost a 30 increase on the uk because
of course
but once again it seems like 30 grams is
just a really unrealistic serving size i
think again i'm eating much closer to 60
grams does that look about right to you
irene
yeah i agree with harry this is again
it's you need to fill the bowl so
apparently filling the bowl means 60
grams so no one's pouring out 37 grams
of cheerios this is i think this is how
much normal people are pouring out so
realistically you're only actually
getting nine and a half servings out of
the uk's largest box whereas we're
getting 15 servings from our largest bag
wow you guys are getting kind of ripped
off
unfortunately we don't have any
exclusive frosties in the uk here are
all the frosted flakes from the u.s that
you won't find in the uk we have the
chocolate frosted flakes frosted flakes
with marshmallows frosted flakes
cinnamon basketballs honey nut frosted
flakes frosted flakes and fruit loops
mashup this is limited edition and the
tiger paws jumbo snacks
i'll try one of the basketballs
tastes like cinnamon i don't think it's
that good shaq
will put his face on literally anything
look at that smile he has on that face
right there that's that i'm getting paid
he's hanging out with tony the tiger
right he also does a commercial with the
general space jam should have been that
i should have been shaq with all the
cartoon characters of products that he
advertises with the shaq the general
tony the tiger uh a can of arizona iced
tea what else is he doing that would
have been a much better movie
this this is exciting this is this is a
fake novel just a real novelty these are
literally like lucky charms i'm only
eating the marshmallows and you know it
turned to milk like purple or pink or
like a weird ugly color but it tastes so
good
i'm sorry you can't have this harry
you know it's probably banned in the uk
because of the hormones or like
artificial products anyway these are
interesting
oh my god okay
this looks like the baby cereal like the
baby's neck or like the toddler snacks
they are it looks like the baby cereal
it's like
but it's like a little bit bigger very
exciting
it's not dry it's not as sweet i would
add more sugar to this
i'm like my dipping sugar
unfortunately we don't have any
exclusive cheerio options in the uk
here are all the cheerios you'll find in
the u.s but not in the uk
here we have the more fruity flavors
blueberry cheerios apple cinnamon
cheerios
cheerios with strawberries very berry
cheerios chocolate strawberry cheerios
and fruity cheerios
is this supposed to be like their take
on fruit loops like healthy fruit loops
so
we have
pumpkin spice cheerios honey nut
cheerios medley
cinnamon cheerios
maple cheerios
frosted cheerios
chocolate peanut butter cheerios
cheerios oat crunch oats and honey
and cheerios oat crunch almond
we weren't able to get our hands on the
limited edition flavors toasted coconut
peach and banana nut i'm a big pumpkin
spice girl i think it's good
it smells like fall
honestly i don't even know if this is
that good or i'm just like it's pumpkin
spice i'm just automatically thinking it
it smells and tastes good but
i think this would be amazing
[Music]
here are some british cereals which you
won't find in the u.s here are some
cereals you won't find in the uk
let's start with the u.s classic lucky
charms i do think they are a classic and
the marshmallows are really good they do
taste very artificial but they're
supposed to taste artificial and i stand
by that i've never had lucky charms
before i had to go to one of those
american shops on oxford street to get
one so are those all marshmallows all
those colorful things
it tastes like a marshmallow but it's
like crunchy marshmallows aren't
supposed to be crispy guys
i'd be lying if i said those weren't
good
that is good everything about the design
of this is just to like make a child go
oh my god i need this yes american
cereal boxes look like slot machines
that is by design so next up
we've got
fruit loops
i like fruit loops is one of those
cereals you can eat dry because they
have enough flavor to them
colors are so fun
how fun that is
there's something wrong with this one
danny dinner used to taste like this
they used to use artificial red dye and
they switched to a natural one
they went too natural also never tried
these
i like the toucan guy he's cool
jesus christ
the smell of those
what is that
it smells like soap or like shower gel
yeah or like yeah like a tropical a
tropical shampoo like a cheap body wash
no i don't like that
the same acidic smell that i got you can
taste that as well and that is not
something that you want with like milk
and finally
crunch
i think the other like
traditional sugary cereals are just
superior to it this is just so like
it doesn't offer anything you know
you can see where all the yellow five
and yellow six are going
they are crunchy as the name suggests
they're pretty good it's between these
or lucky charms fruit loops for me are
awful never stop eating those
we'll start with a personal favorite of
mine which is golden nuggets i'm a
little surprised you don't have these in
the us because the kind of uh advert
campaign was based around prospecting
and the gold rush so we've got like a
little mascot gold miner guy who i think
his name was like prospected or
something like that i do feel like they
used to be brighter than that yeah but
uh they've got rid of the catchphrase
and also yeah demoted the the mascot to
the back of the pack uh the catchphrase
when i remember growing up with these
was they taste yeehaw
okay they taste yeehaw what would be the
uk equivalent of that in america british
parliament flakes what'd you just say
parliament pops they taste jolly good
i don't think they taste quite as yee-ha
as i remember from my childhood but
still like a solid mid to low level of
yeehaw next up we've got weetabix now i
personally love weetabix but i will say
it's quite a boring cereal if you
imagine the kind of like archetypal
really boring gray british breakfast
it's probably one of these it's
literally just compressed wheat
with a very small amount of sugar and i
think some enriched
vitamins and minerals like they have no
right to be as good as they are but they
are just good like i can't i can't
explain why as long as the milk is
really cold
so that you get the crisp that's
maintained
to me
that's just pure nostalgia
so
we got
harry's
british cereal i'm very confused by this
i'm scared i'm gonna follow harry's
tutorial
okay
i don't think you can just call
something cereal because you're pouring
milk on top of it
and i feel like that's what's happening
here
like this kind of feels like if i were
to get a granola bar and pour milk on
top of it and i was going to be like oh
i'm eating cereal now
i don't want to say it tastes like
cardboard but it tastes like cardboard
my childhood was fruity pebbles i'm
sorry it was rainbows and unicorns and
magical flavors if you dip want a
slightly more exciting version of
weetabix then they do have flavoured
ones as well for example these are the
classic biscuits but banana flavoured
there are also some classic ones but
chocolate flavoured then they have a few
other options as well such as these ones
which are chocolate melts so it's kind
of like a weetabix outside layer but
then with like a little bit of chocolate
inside and these come with milk
chocolate or with white chocolate and
then finally maybe my favorite cereal
ever we to mix crispy minis these things
are incredible it's a little bite-sized
versions of weetabix with a bunch of
chocolate chips in them honestly god
tear cereal this is supposed to be like
the treat version
food is supposed to make you feel better
a final uk solution for today are wetos
now not so much of a fan of these myself
they're kind of like uh cheerios in that
they're a ring shape however they're a
little bit bigger a little bit like more
puffy and airy and personally i just
don't love that because you know when
you're eating them with the milk they go
a little bit more soggy more quickly
yeah i'm sure some people like them but
not myself
[Music]
this is a more realistic serving of 60
grams of frosted flakes if we do some
quick math we can figure out that the
nutrition for this is as follows 210
calories zero grams of fat 53.4 grams of
carbs 19.2 grams of which are sugar 1.62
grams of fiber and 307 milligrams of
sodium so here's everything that's in 60
grams of frosties in the uk 225 calories
0.36 grams of fat of which 0.06 grams
are saturated carbs 52.2 grams of which
22.2 grams are sugar fiber 1.4 grams and
232 milligrams of sodium the final thing
to note is that these values don't
include milk so in the states we have a
few different types of milk with varying
fat content skim milk which has zero
percent fat one percent milk two percent
milk and then whole milk which is around
three point twenty five percent fat for
this example we're going to use two
percent milk in the uk we don't refer to
our milks by fat percentage instead we
call them skimmed semi-skimmed and whole
milk they're around zero percent two
percent and three point five percent fat
respectively for this example we'll use
semi-skimmed milk
so in the uk we also standardized the
colors of our milk so green is always
semi-skimmed blue is always whole milk
and red is skim milk whereas i spoke to
a few american friends and those are
just like all over the place depending
on where the country you are and it
seems like an absolute minefield so in
the u.s 100 milliliters of two percent
milk contains the following
50 calories 2.08 grams of total fat 1.25
grams of which are saturated 5 grams of
carbs of which 5 grams of sugar so all
the carbs of sugar and 52 milligrams of
sodium in the uk 100 milliliters of
semi-skimmed milk contains the following
50 calories 1.8 grams of fat of which
1.1 grams are saturated 4.8 grams of
carbs of which 4.8 grams are sugar and
40 milligrams of sodium our research
suggests that the average bowl of cereal
contains around 200 milliliters of milk
so these figures need to be
doubled
then we can add those stats to our
realistic 60 gram serving and the final
tally looks something like this
so the same bowl in the u.s would
contain this
so the uk version is actually more
calorific and more sugary while the u.s
version has more fat total carbs and
sodium because of course we do the main
thing to watch out for here is of course
the sugar the recommended daily added
sugar intake for an adult is 50 grams
and this contains over 60 percent of
that
we're gonna measure it out for you now
so you can see just how much sugar is in
one of these bowls
oh my god stop eating so much sugar
i feel like this is bad to say but this
isn't as much sugar as i thought there'd
be i thought that every more and like
sometimes i add more sugar to my cereal
so like
cereal is meant to be sugary i stand by
that so it's like i don't trust people
who eat like raisin bran raisin bran
people can't be trusted this is probably
about as much sugar i add to my coffee
so
look at okay this is a little bit more
sugar than i would do
my stomach hurts just watching this this
is genuinely good to me the 31.8 grams
of sugar in this bowl of frosties is
actually less than three american glazed
ring krispy kreme donuts so uh yeah i
guess you can just eat those for
breakfast instead here's the nutritional
info for a 60 gram bowl of honey
cheerios in the uk and here are the
values for a 60 gram honey nut cheerio
bowl in the u.s here's how the values
change if we add milk
so this bowl only contains around 16 of
your daily calories but
once again it's the sugar you need to
watch out for there's almost 60 percent
of your daily sugar allowance in here
it's not quite as bad in the uk at just
46 of your daily sugar but that is still
quite a lot for your breakfast the good
news for the uk is that we somehow have
45 less sodium than the us bowl
[Music]
here are all the ingredients in frosties
in the uk
maize sugar barley malt flavoring salt
vitamins and minerals niacin iron b6 b2
b1 folic acid vitamin d and vitamin b12
yes we pronounce it vitamins not
vitamins
here are all the ingredients and frosted
flakes in the u.s milled corn sugar malt
flavor salt vitamins and minerals iron
niacinamide vitamin b6 vitamin b2
vitamin b1 folic acid vitamin d3 and
vitamin b12 the differences here are
actually just linguistic in practical
terms those are basically identical
lists things get more interesting when
we move away from classic frosted flakes
take these frosted flakes with crispy
cinnamon basketballs for example here's
the ingredients list for these
two things to watch out for here first
the yellow six this is a food coloring
which is used to give things a yellowy
orange color but you're unlikely to see
it on any ingredients list in the uk it
was flagged in a 2008 study as one of
six colorings that may be linked to
hyperactivity in kids if it's in a uk
food product it must come with a warning
that it may have an adverse effect on
activity and attention in children the
other ingredients watch out for here is
bht or butylated hydroxytoluene this is
an antioxidant which is used to keep
foods fresh outside of food use some use
it to treat herpes if that's not enough
to put you off there are also some
studies which have suggested that bht
causes rats to develop tumors
yay
there's actually very little evidence to
suggest that it could do the same to
humans but its use is still restricted
in places like australia and certain
companies such as general mills have
voluntarily taken steps to remove it
from all their products
here's everything in honey cheerios in
the uk here is everything in honey nut
cheerios in the u.s these are pretty
similar lists with a few minor
differences in the uk we seem to put a
bit more emphasis on the grains with
wheat barley maize and rice all being
involved compared to just oats in the us
while we're doing a serial episode we
may as well look at the milk used in
both the uk and the us you may have seen
certain headlines suggesting that u.s
milk is actually banned in the european
union that's not completely correct but
there are some differences to note which
do cause issues with imports the first
issue is due to something called somatic
cells these are basically just the white
blood cells which cows will produce to
fight infections when they get sick if
you have a high somatic cell count in
your milk it's probably a sign that it
came from a less healthy cow the general
limit for a healthy cow is considered to
be around 100 000 cells per milliliter
with 200 000 getting towards mastitis
territory which is when the others get
infected for milk to be sold in the
european union the somatic cell count
can't be any higher than 400 000 cells
per milliliter but in the us it's almost
double that you guys have an upper
threshold of 750 000 cells per
milliliter which means that in general
you guys tolerate much sicker cows than
we do in the uk and the eu
not the sacred cows
i feel like every time we do one of
these it's basically just the uk being
like so you guys don't standardize
anything you don't regulate anything and
we're like
yeah
the one chocolate chip in my pellet
really makes me feel really happy i
don't need sugar or flavors or color